I don't believe in the Bible uh well
your Prophet did so that means you're
better than your Prophet so go to Romans
chapter 8 Romans was written by Paul not
Jesus here we go we have Sam shamon
lying to a Muslim lay man so he claimed
that Prophet
Muhammad believed in the Bible that this
is a pure lie because in the Quran Allah
never mentioned the word bible what is
we mention the Quran is the tah and in
Orab ref the tah or inj all right
J speaking all the Quran so we Muslims
yes we believe in the scriptures that
was given by God to the prophets like
Moses Jesus the word bible is in the
Quran to begin with so why you lying say
Prophet Muhammad believe in the Bible so
Prophet Muhammad believed in in James
and I mean in Mark and Luke and Matthew
and John what are you lying for but what
we find in the Quran that yes Allah said
to his Prophet say that we believe in
the scripture that was given to you and
scriptures was given to us so what was
scriptures given to the Jesus and Moses
is the and the Torah so look how this
this person is known to be a liar and a
deceiver Subhan Allah because they
cannot refute us with truth they have to
lie to turn people away from the
truth Jesus okay but and the Quran was
written by Muhammad not Jesus and you
still believe what Muhammad says about
Jesus yes
this is another lie of Sam shamon uh
deceiving and lying to our Muslim
brother he said Quran was was written by
the prophet
Muhammad it is well known that Quran
firstly was revealed by Allah the
almighty the creator of everything to
Prophet
Muhammad who received the Revelation
read out his companions his companions
used to write down the Quran then there
out back to him to make sure there's
nothing missing all right as for the
Bible and for also the Quran makes claim
that the Quran is from the from Allah
the almighty the Bible Mark Luke John
Matthew none of them claim that they
were inspired by God even Paul when Paul
said all scriptures was inspired by God
the New Testament was even written
during his lifetime so the Christians
call say Paul was referring to the Torah
or the Old Testament so the the the
Bible doesn't even make claim rather
what we do find in Luke that clearly
said he the the reason he wrote the
Bible or the reason he wrote his gospel
because many people have
written so and how he wrote it not
because he was inspired inspired by God
because people eyewitnesses pass down
narrations to him so the Sam
uh keeps lying and deceiving his
followers so yes I believe what Muhammad
who came 600 years later tells me about
Jesus in Arabic a language Jesus didn't
speak another uh false argument that Sam
Shaman trying to utilize against our
Muslim
brother his argument is that you're
gonna believe in the prophet
Muhammad said something about Jesus in
the language that Jesus never spoke okay
so therefore according to him to believe
in some some to believe um someone about
something or about someone else he's
going to tell you he must tell you in
that person's language argument is this
okay let us flip the table before
flipping the table firstly is not the
prophet Muhammad who from his own
desires and his own head told us about
Jesus and uh about his life and
everything it was Allah the almighty the
knower of everything the the one who
knows what happened in the past in
detail and what's happening right now in
detail and what is going to happen in
the future in detail he told us through
his Prophet about the mighty messenger
the true Messiah the servant of Allah
Jesus as for the Bible the people that
taught us about Jesus in the Bible the
or the new test Testament by people who
don't even know
them like let us understand one point
the the the earliest manuscript that we
have for the New Testament is literally
100 years after the the actual
writings do we know them we don't know
them are they trustworthy if we don't
know them how can we trust
them the other thing which this
individual uh so to flip the table on
him you have the Torah speak speaks
about Abraham speaks about Noah in the
language they never spoke so therefore
we should not believe them because the
Torah is in Hebrew and Noah and Abraham
never spoke in
Hebrew what what what an argument is
this but this is the outcome of when you
try to oppose God's teaching God will
make you say things which is the most
silly things and all praise be to Allah
the creator of everything come to Islam
Islam goes in L with our sound intellect
natural inclination not like
Christianity there's three God but only
one God Jesus is fully God the father is
fully God the holy spirit is fully God
but there are only one God I mean which
school you been to 1 + 1 + one is equal
one + one 1 + 1 + one is equal three but
according to Christian logic is one so
tell us which which school you've been
to to call the government and urgently
they have to knock it down